In this problem, we're going
to look at the probability
that when you take a stick and
break it into three pieces
randomly that these three pieces
can actually be used to
form a triangle.
All right, so we start
out with a stick of
unit length, so--
length 1.
And we'll choose a point along
the stick to break.
And we'll choose that point
uniformly at random.
So let's say that we chose it
here, that was the point where
we'll break it.
And then independently of this
first choice we'll again
choose a second point
to break it.
Again, uniformly at random
along the entire stick.
So let's say the second point
we chose was here.
So what we have now is, we'll
break it here, here, and so
we'll have three pieces--
the first one, the left
one and the right one.
And we want to know, what's the
probability that when you
take these three pieces you
could form a triangle?
So the first thing we
should ask ourselves
is, what do you need--
what conditions must be
satisfied in order to actually
be able to form a triangle
with three pieces?
So you could think about, what
would stop you from being able
to do that?
Well, one possibility is
that you have pieces
that look like this.
So in that case you would
try to form something
that looks like this.
But you can't get a triangle
because these two pieces are
too short and they can't
touch each other.
So actually the condition that
must be satisfied is that when
you take any two of the three
pieces, their combined length
has to be greater than
the length of the
remaining third piece.
And that has to be true
for any two pieces.
And really that's just so that
any two pieces, they can touch
and still form a triangle.
So let's try to add some
probability to this.
So we have a unit
length stick.
So let's actually give
a coordinate system.
The stick goes from 0 to 1.
And let's say that we break
it at these two points.
So the first point where we
choose, we'll call that x.
So that's the first point that
we choose to break it.
And then the second point we
choose, we'll call that y.
Now note that I've drawn it so
that x is to the left of y.
But it could actually be the
case that the first point I
chose is here and the
second point that I
chose is to the left.
But for now, let's
first assume that
this scenario holds.
That the first point is to the
left of the second point.
So under this assumption,
we can see that--
from the definition of these
random variables-- we can
actually see that the
lengths are given
by these three lengths.
So the lengths are x, the left
most piece has length x.
The second, middle piece
has length y minus x.
And the last piece has
length 1 minus y.
And now let's recall our
three conditions.
So the conditions were that any
two of these, the sum of
any two lengths, has
to be at least--
has to be greater than the
length of the third piece.
So let's do these together.
So x plus y minus x has to be
greater than 1 minus y.
So with these two pieces you
can cover this third piece.
We also need that with the first
and third pieces, we can
cover the middle piece.
And we need with the second and
third pieces, we can cover
the first piece.
Now this looks kind of messy,
but in fact we can actually
simplify this.
So this actually simplifies.
x minus x, that disappears.
And so this actually simplifies
to 2y has
to be at least 1.
Or even more simply, y has
to be greater than 1/2.
What about this one?
This one, we can rearrange
things again.
x we can move over.
y we can move over here.
And we get that 2x plus 1 has
to be greater than 2y.
Or put in other words, y is
less than x plus 1/2.
And for the last one, again
we can simplify.
The y's cancel each other out.
And we're left with
2x is less than 1.
Or x is less than 1/2.
So these are our three
conditions
that need to be satisfied.
So now we just have to figure
out what's the probability
that this is actually
satisfied?
Now let's go back to original
definition and see what are
the actual distributions
for these random
variables, x and y.
Remember, we defined them to
be x is the location of the
first break and y is the
location of the second break.
And as we said in the problem,
these are chosen uniformly at
random and they're
independent.
And so we can actually draw
out their joint PDF.
So x and y, you can cover
any point in the square.
And moreover, it's actually
uniform within the square.
Because each one is chosen
uniformly at random and
they're independent.
So it's anywhere in here.
And so what do we need to do?
We just need to identify, what
is the probability that these
three conditions hold?
Rewrite this, line these up.
So these are our three
conditions that we need.
And now remember, we're still
working under the assumption
that the first point that we
chose is actually to the left
of the second point.
So what does that mean?
That means that we are
actually in this top
triangle, top half--
x is less than y.
All right, so what do we need?
We need y to be at least
1/2, so here's 1/2.
So we need y to be
above this line.
We need x to be less than 1/2.
So we need x to be to
the left of here.
So now so far we're stuck
in this upper square.
And the last thing we need is y
to be less than x plus 1/2.
What is y?
The line y equals x and a 1/2,
x plus 1/2, is this one.
So y has to be less than that,
so it would have to be in this
triangle here.
So these three conditions tell
us that in order for us to
have a triangle we need to for
x and y to fall jointly in
this small triangle here.
Now because the joint
distribution is uniform, we
know that the density
is just 1, right?
Because the area
here is just 1.
So the height is
just 1 as well.
And so the density, or the
probability of falling within
this small triangle, is just
going to be also the area of
this triangle.
And what is the area
of this triangle?
Well, you can fit 8 of these
triangles in here, or you
could think of it as 1/2
times 1/2 times 1/2.
So the area is just 1/8.
So assuming that x is less than
y, then the probability
of forming a triangle is 1/8.
Now, that's only half
this story, though.
Because it's possible that when
you chose these two break
points that we actually had
the opposite result.
That x, the point that you
chose first, falls to the
right of the point that
you chose second.
In which case everything
kind of flips.
Now we assume that y is less
than x, which means that now
we're in this lower triangle
in the square.
Now we can go through this
whole exercise again.
But really, what we can see is
that all we've really done is
just swap the names.
Instead of having x and y we now
call x-- we call x y and
we call y x.
And so if we just swap names,
we can see that--
let's just fast forward through
all these steps and
see that we could just swap
names here, too, as well, in
the three conditions.
So instead of needing y to be
greater than 1/2, we just need
x to be greater than 1/2.
Instead of having x less than
1/2, we need y less than 1/2.
We also swap this.
So we need x to be less than y
plus 1/2 or y is greater than
x minus 1/2.
All right, now let's figure out
what this corresponds to.
We need x to be greater than
1/2, so it needs to be to the
right of here.
We need y to be less than
1/2, so we need it to
be below this line.
And we need y to be greater
than x minus 1/2.
What is the line y equals
x minus 1/2?
That is this line here.
And we need y to be greater than
that, so it needs to be
above this line.
And so we get that this is the
triangle, the small triangle
that we need in this case.
And notice that it's exactly
the same area
as this one, right?
And so we get another
contribution of 1/8 here.
So the final answer is
1/8 plus 1/8 is 1/4.
So the probability of forming
a triangle using this three
pieces is exactly 1/4.
And so notice that we've done
is, you've set things up very
methodically in the beginning
by assigning
these random variables.
And you consider different
cases.
Because you don't actually know
the order in which x and
y might fall, let's just assume
that one particular
order and work from there.
And then do the other
case, as well.
And it just so happened that
because of the symmetry of the
problem the second case was
actually very simple.
We could just see that it is
actually symmetric and so we
get the same answer.
So this is kind of an
interesting problem because
it's actually a practical
application of something that
you might actually do.
And you can see that just by
applying these probability
concepts you can actually--